homogeneous
Chat ihr seid ja schon so viel hier wo kommen denn alle her so schnell ich habe gedacht ich mache stream an, geh mal aufs Klo schon wieder alles voll
Massive chat
Shirato 222 Poggers, aber richtig Poggers, ich wollte ich voll vergessen richtig Pobbers was ist denn Pobbers
Pobbers ist dann eher sowas danke schön für drei Monate huge subscription
Discord notification gang nice exquisite
So also ich mach kurz die musik ein bisschen leiser
Bei schmach engle Pippo dance musik an
So also verlängert die subscription sich eigentlich von selbst
Das ist eine gute frage prime subscriptions glaube ich nicht
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
Aber anscheinend ja aber du kannst subscriben und direkt danach wieder weg machen falls du das nicht willst
primes laufen aus genau
Heute arch wird interessant ja mal gucken wie die xfc geschichte ist leute ich mache das heute nicht dass wir arch installieren sondern
hauptsächlich weil ich mal wieder kompets installieren will ich habe gestern doch im video so die
so ein paar effekte gezeigt nicht wollte einfach mal ausprobieren
Ob man das unter dem aktuellen linux noch auf die reihe kriegt ja
Was wäre es möglich ein skript zu progern welches mein primes ab automatisch bei dir einlösen würde
Bestimmt ja
Also ich meine die einfachste variante sowas zu machen ist ein headless chrome
Papetier oder irgendwas in der richtung
Chrome fernsteuern das würde dann halt im endeffekt nur das machen was du auch machst von hand
nur halt automatisch aber man kann bestimmt das noch schöner machen
Ja kannst du dir nach als wort angucken falls ich nicht was liege dann ist das wort wieder weg
baust du das bis
Nein das baue ich nicht nach ich verwende noch gar keinen knolm warum verwende ich keinen knolm weil der weil der der scheiß knolm ist
den verwendet man nicht
Leute ich muss euch was erzählen heute hatte ich das hat heute war echt was was mich echt mega verwirrt hat ne
cute bunto ich ich ich machs ich machs kommen hier weil ihr seid leute
weil ihr seid solange ich euch jetzt noch was erzählen machen wir das machen wir cute die cute 4m an
Cute 4m
Ich bin echt sehr froh dass ihr euch jetzt noch was erzählen könntet ihr euch jetzt noch was erzählen
Die cute 4m an cute 4m lädt achtung cute 4m loading
So was ist die cute 4m gecrashed ah ne die hatten bildschirm schon an warum sind sowas cute 4m am start
Exzellent ist das nicht super so die cute 4m ist da
Alter mein headset spackt wieder jetzt geht's los gestern überhaupt kein problem jetzt jetzt spinnt's wieder rum
Wartet mal
So wunderbar
Was 2021
2020 ausbildung als systementwickler oder anwender was hat das denn mit 2021 zu tun willst du 2021
Ausbildung machen weil ich mein das ist 2021 genauso wie 2020 oder mit 2022 du musst wissen was du machen willst
Das kann man nicht pauschal sagen es taugt beides kann man beides machen
Quatsch es kommt darauf an was man machen will
Das kann man beides machen das ist es spricht nicht irgendwie was dagegen eines davon zu machen
Was willst du denn machen das ist eigentlich die hauptsächliches sache die man sich die man sich fragen muss oder oder vielleicht noch besser
wenn man
Wenn du eine firma hast wo du unbedingt hin willst ja oder wo du sagst hey die finde ich finde ich super und die sind bei dir in der nähe und die haben nur
Die haben nur systemintegration dann würde ich mir das auch überlegen
Systemintegration dann würde ich mir das auch überlegen
Ja also es hängt von das hängt echt von dir ab
Also leute cute cute bunto also ich wollte euch was erzählen was hat mich heute nämlich echt es hat mich heute echt ein bisschen verwirrt
Und zwar heute mittag klingels telefon
Und ich habe jetzt keine ahnung wer das ist
Bis ich dann drauf gekommen bin
Dass es der sohn vom nachbar ist der mich anruft der sohn vom nachbar
Der mich fragen
gefragt
Also fragen wollte ob ich ihm bei windows netzwerk settings helfen kann
Ich weiß nicht wie er auf mich kommt ich habe mit ihm glaube ich noch nicht noch nicht einsatz gewechselt in den acht jahren wo ich hier wohne
Aber aus irgendwelchen gründen hat er mitgekriegt ich kenne mich damit wahrscheinlich aus vielleicht guckt er mal in stream ich weiß es nicht
Vielleicht guckt er mal in stream ich weiß es nicht und ich habe keine ahnung
Ich habe legit keine ahnung vielleicht ist einer meiner mods ja kann schon sein ich weiß nicht wie alt er ist 15 oder so
Ich glaube nicht dass der mein stream guckt aber da hat mich angerufen wegen windows windows netzwerk da konnte ich ihm gar nicht helfen
So wir müssen die cute vm ausmachen
Genug cute vm
Yes critical informations ja der leckt sie nicht
Also meinst du system integrator ist zukunftsfähig beides zukunftsfähig du musst einfach
Beides zukunftsfähig du musst einfach was können
Du musst was können das ist das wichtigste dabei
Wenn du nichts kannst dann bringt dir das weder als anwendungsentwickler noch als system integrator was
Bost einfach was können
Das hört sich jetzt so an es oder du musst einfach was können das ist ungefähr genauso wie wenn man wie wenn man sagt
Und online games online games sind sind doof du musst doch einfach nur gewinnen ja aber du musst halt einfach nur was können
So simpel
Macht auch die zwei neuen informatik aus kannst du auch machen wenn du da einen findest der das ausschreibt gibt der relativ selten
Just five vorher dir
Ja man kann das auch machen wenn es da was gutes gibt
Fachinformatik am first level excellent ja gut es gibt ein paar sachen die würde ich nicht empfehlen da gehört das dazu
so also ich leg mal kurz den vm an cute warum habe ich überhaupt noch genug platz
ha ha es wird eng leute es wird eng so langsam aber sicher hier im vm land aber das ist nicht
schlimm weil man ganzes andere zeug habe ich ja auf einer acht terabyte platte die habe ich
jetzt aber nicht gemontet im stream weil ich dazu viel liege aber für eine weitere vm reicht
das noch also vielleicht sollten wir uns erst mal das iso downloaden würde ich sagen also was
ich heute vorhabe zu machen ist folgendes ich zeige es euch mal ich will mal gucken ob man
ein aktuelles linux so stylisch auf war also also wie wird man das so stylisch total über
engineern kann wie man das früher gemacht hat zu 2010 rum ob man zum beispiel heute noch ein
aktuellen linux desktop so einen geilen würfeln machen kann draus beste ja also wir werden jetzt
in den artsch in den manjaro xfc installieren wir brauchen wir brauchen den xfc oder irgendwas
was nicht geht egal genau michel mäßig ist und auch kein kde und was fenster hat und da fällt
mir erstmal nur xfc ein und manjaro weil es aktuell paketversionen hat tora sind 8 eine 187
dankeschön für drei monate hyper subscription so wir legen wir legen jetzt mal jetzt mal
exzellente vm an hier die quatsch was mache ich erst mal das iso runterladen manjaro xfc
e bäm downloads wo man aus get xfc heißt es eigentlich xfc oder heißt es xfc also ich ich
persönlich bin er für xfc so minimal ach komm nähe kommen wir nehmen das normale und gut ist
mal gucken mal gucken wie das wie das ausschaut ob es überhaupt taugt oh 2,4 g leute kritisch
es wird kritisch kommt mal hier das ist das ist die gigabyte schon runter zählen hier seht
ihr das dann jetzt runter easy so ich glaube wir müssen ein paar sachen wegschmeißen
zwar das noch mal das war die home assistant iso ok wenn es ja gut wenn es kann ich eigentlich
löschen wenn es wird eh nix mehr aber ich habe hier gar nicht so viel verbraucht wo
ist wo gehen der ganze speicherplatz hin monka es alda ist denn hier los so während das
iso download kann ich noch mal kurz gucken doch habe ich aber das bringt ja im rechner
jetzt hier nix äh bei welchen provider ich bin bei dem äh was ist das jetzt unity media
ist jetzt vodafone genau tja es gibt in deutschland eigentlich nur schlechte provider alter zu
geil ne die leute wieder ab start sind so also iso läuft unity media ist richtiger trash
seitdem es vodafone gehört das war vorher doch auch schon trash oder
also im prinzip war es schon immer trash das täuscht die unterschiede sind relativ groß
es gibt allerdings so viele distributionen die vielleicht auf 5 6 verschiedenen äh quasi
hauptdistros basieren deswegen sind die sich so ähnlich aber wenn du zum beispiel mal
nen gendu und nen debian vergleicht oder nen archlinux und nen suze oder sonstwas da wirst
du schon feststellen das sind ganz schön viele unterschiede dabei das archwiki ist
das beste das geht das meiste geht das meiste das meiste geht unter mancharo auch ey facecam
es gibt bald nen 3d kicks der reden kann mit euch wenn das mit pfeiffer so funktioniert
lull ist dann eher seh ich mach das eher so just for fun mal gucken ob das funktioniert
da bin ich aber echt gespannt ja das das wird das wird das wird richtig lustig sag
ich euch ich mach natürlich dann richtiges clickbait video face reveal fragezeichen und
dann mach ich so nen kopf so so halt so halb kicks und halb eingeschwärzt und dann richtig
huge clickbait leute morgen morgen kommt übrigens ein neues video auf youtube da lasse ich mich
drüber aus ich hab euch die story ja schon mal erzählt wobei im rechenzentrums umbau
das fenster kaputt gegangen ist das habe ich ein bisschen ausgeschmückt für für youtube
bisschen mehr details ja ne ohne fragezeichen ohne fragezeichen natürlich ja das teppich
richtig richtig der chat weiß noch das teppich rechtenzentrum und da ist hetzer sponsoring
dabei ich brauche jetzt nur noch einen guten titel und ein gutes thumbnail guten titel
guten titel habe ich schon ich werde wahrscheinlich sowas machen wie wie notfall im rechenzentrum
oder sowas näh das ist zu übertrieben hatte man gute idee guten titel also im prinzip
gehts ja in der ganzen story drum dass wir beim einlassen also dass wir ne also dort
wo ich gearbeitet hab der provider hat nen rechenzentrum im dritten stock gemietet also
nein eine wohnung im dritten stock gemietet und weil sie in der innenstadt nen rechenzentrum
gebraucht haben das war halt absolut nicht dafür geeignet das war noch komplett mit
mit teppich und allem und das war halt richtig richtig fail und da haben sie versucht nen
ibm storage durchs fenster zu buxieren so schräg musstest du ja schräg machen durftest
du dann auch in eine ganz spezielle ecke stellen tainser 22 monat halber subscribeschen dankeschön
für die ganzen subs hier massive und dabei ist dann halt erst die fensterbank abgebrochen
und danach war das fenster kaputt und man hat es nicht mehr zu gekriegt was halt für
die lüftung im rechenzentrum äh nicht für die lüftung für die kühlung im rechenzentrum
so schlecht ist hat jemand irgendwie big brain titel idee das war tatsächlich guter april
scherz rechenzentrum fast explodiert omg da schreibt man schreibt man doch nicht omg
dahinter da schreibt man hin gone sexual und macht dann so ein eggplant und splash emoji
dahinter guckt sowas hier so müsste man das eigentlich machen so müsste man das eigentlich
machen sexual und dann brauchen wir moment moment moment eggplant emoji genau das da
moment moment moment notepad moment notepad kann das natürlich nicht also wir brauchen
sowas hier consequence und dann und dann emoji splash das da das ist doch das ist doch schon
mal nicht schlecht oder das ist das ist schon mal nicht das ist schon mal nicht nicht verkehrt
das finde ich schon mal ganz gut ja der rollstuhl hälter ja da ist dass du am start bist hier
ach nee mir fällt da nichts so wirklich gutes ein ich muss da noch mal in mich gehen fenster
kaputt heißt direkte verbindung in die cloud sozusagen ja das ist zu lang aber unglaublich
ist schon mal gut unglaublich ist schon mal gut was auch was auch beliebt ist sind so
sind zu überschriften so tue dies tue das niemals oder sowas server server zerstört
haus das finde ich eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht server zerstört haus und dann muss
doch irgendwas in klammern dahinter server zerstört haus und was kann man da noch was
kann man da noch dahinter machen ja ja ich weiß ich weiß auch nicht warum ich das nicht
verwende server zerstört haus und dann ne klimakatastrophe no click genau click bed ist
natürlich auch gut ne ne ne ne ne ne ich kann ich kann wenn da ein hetzer sponsoring drin
ist doch nicht o v h in den titel schreiben die steigen wir aufs dach groundbreaking ja
der boden war tatsächlich ziemlich kaputt das ist gar nicht so weit so weit von der
realität entfernt gone wild ane irgendwas was passt irgendwas was passt server zerstört
haus contron ja die die die die die die die die die tatsächlich gar nicht so verkehrt
dass das dahinter zu machen so was zerstört ok ich wäre ich will ich überleg mir morgen
etwas gutes ich überleg mir morgen etwas gutes unglaubliche geschichte hatte ich in
Letzterzeit schon mal
Server zerstört windows das ist tatsächlich echt geile idee aber das checken die leute nicht
Kaum zu glauben
Das finde ich gut kaum zu glauben
Heutzutage du hast heute keine chance mehr auf youtube wenn du wenn du nicht irgendwie ein bisschen clickbait ist guckt euch das hier alles
an na gut meine meine sache ist ja nicht auslagekräftig ja
musik und technik sachen aber
Ups
Albermann mega back door in der cloud ist das so
Captain pengen dankeschön sechs monate subscription huge
Also chat wenn ihr noch eine gute idee habt dann haut rein ich lege jetzt erst noch mal die vm an
Für unsere huge
Highly effekt big brain form
macha installation
So next next next linux ja gut ist es eigentlich egal was wir da nehmen ein aktuelles 16 bit kernel zack
Nein nein nein wir machen das definitiv definitiv nicht da
sondern unter
e-doppelpunkt
vms vms
vms
Make new folder
Effekte
So next ja drei cpus muss schon sein
Ein number of course eine cpu muss schon sein und by the way er hat mir letztens einer im
Im stream erzählt man kann einfach hier draufklicken und klickt direkt 8 gigabyte wusste ich nicht ich habe immer hier so rumgefuddelt
Oder hier zeug eingetragen einfach hier auf acht drücken und beim easy muss man erst mal wissen messen messen was man hier wieder lernt leute
Erst mal consulting kosten gespart schulungskosten gespart einfach hier wo bloß streamen gucken
thomas stichs stufe eins dankeschön für den sub
Ich erzähl das jeden stream das ist richtig aber sind auch jeden stream immer viele leute dabei die es noch nie gehört haben
Hast du die diskussion auf eise mitbekommen da wurden bewusst schwachstellen die nungskörner eingeschleudet eingeschleudet habe ich mitkriegt mitgekriegt
angeblich aus wissenschaftlichen gründen von irgendeiner uni
Die die die 8 g na 8 g ist ein bisschen wenig 40 g na ja nicht 409 40 g
So weg
Netzwerk drin drucke wir machen wir machen dings boot würde ich sagen oder wir machen gleich
Uefi boot man weiß ja nie vielleicht ist das
Vielleicht ist das gar nicht so verkehrt für mehr effects display
Accelerate 3d graphics ja das muss auf jeden fall sein sonst funktioniert das
So und jetzt legen wir die cd ein
Wo ist unser mancharo repo downloads repo was lauf ich noch mal mancharo iso
zack power on
Ifinished install ja ja ich hab's gefinished
Komplett finished install so also ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich hab noch nie ich hab noch nie in mancharo xfc installiert
mal
finished
K.t, Enin
E
De exzellent language es ist ok utc sollen wir auch recht sein
Also wie gesagt das arch vq ist wirklich super für alle möglichen sachen ich gucke da auch immer sehr viel
gut der boot champ richtig
Ich habe gar nicht gedacht aber ja der boot champ ist am start
Ich hoffe der boot champ wird nicht zum pains champ weil jetzt irgendwas nicht funktioniert
So
Hab ich irgendwas überleben übersehen überlesen
Ja das stimmt das ist eine bescheuerte aussage das meiste
wäre unter linux oder umgedreht auch passiert wenn man es drauf angelegt hätte
Ich mache da ich mache da übrigens gerne mit so just for fun immer um solche
Um manche leute zu triggern ja
Genau da wollte jemand ein reißerisches paper schreiben ja genau die sagen halt aus wissenschaftlichen zwecken
Auch bei reddit ok da geht es aber voll ab
Ja
Ande dankeschön prime subscriptions oder scam train ist am start leute
Lasst euch mal schön zum samen debaten alle leute ich glaube es funktioniert nicht
Ich sag noch ich sag noch hoffentlich wird der boot nicht zum pains champ
Scheinlich zu funktionieren gleich kaputt aus welchen gründen auch immer
Vielleicht hätte ich doch nicht so ehe viel boot einstellen sollen
Das macht man schau immer ok was macht es denn da hardware erkennung ist das
Hardware erkennung
No limit no limit ist schlecht
Ok wir warten mal kurz vielleicht macht es hier irgendwann weiter
Im zweifelsfall liegt allem alles ans nap
Ja und und ging es bei dir dann irgendwann weiter oder was hast du gemacht
Ich hätte es nicht gedacht dass es schon beim installieren irgendwelche probleme gibt
Pause champ ja richtiger massiv massiver pause champ
Du hast die vm neu gestartet und dann ging es ernsthaft
Pass mal auf wenn das jetzt funktioniert dann lasse ich mich ja kaputt ich habe mal ein bisschen escape steuerung c ne bringt nichts
Ich habe mal ein bisschen escape steuerung c ne bringt nix
Starten wir mal neu vielleicht sollte ich mit proprietary drivers booten
Nope noch
Oh
G baited
Gib ist
Es sah erst so aus als würde es funktionieren und jetzt richtig rein schiebt er es wieder.
So wir machen jetzt was anderes Leute, wir gehen jetzt in die Settings und sagen dem
nicht, achso ich muss vorher ausmachen, der soll gefälligst normal booten.
Schon die Ankündigung für das nächste Battlefield mitbekommen?
Nein, ich habe mitbekommen, dass es einen Battlefield Mobile geben soll, das habe ich
mitbekommen.
Was meinst du?
Meinst du es Battlefield Mobile?
Ja das wundert mich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Ich meine wenigstens haben sie nicht so ein Scheiß gemacht wie bei Diablo Immortal, riesen
Ankündigungen und dann ist es ein Mobile Game und die Leute fühlen sich übelst debatet.
Ich meine Mobile Battlefield, da haben die Leute natürlich danach gefragt.
Gibt uns ein Mobile Battlefield, unbedingt, das brauchen wir.
Habt ihr kein Handy Leute?
Übrigens einer der lustigsten Streams die ich die letzten Jahre über geguckt habe,
jetzt ohne Witz, weil das hier einer schreibt, das war Mobile, wie heißt das Clash of Kings
oder sowas, gibt es dieses, gibt es das?
Mobile Game?
Ne das meine ich nicht, das war so eine Art Tower Defense Spiel, PvP, nicht Clash of Clans,
das war so eine Art Tower Defense, aber PvP, du hattest, ne ne, das war nicht Clash of
Clans, ne ne ne, ich glaube nicht, ich glaube nicht, ne ne ne, Clash Royale, das kann sein,
ja das kann sein, das kann sein, ja, ja, genau das meine ich, genau das meine ich und
eines der, eines der witzigsten Videos oder besser gesagt eines der witzigsten Streams
die ich jahre, den letzten jahre über gesehen habe war, ein eSport Turnier Clash Royale,
da haben die wirklich Caster gehabt und Leute die da an ihren Tablets gesessen haben und
die sind dann richtig abgegangen, oh mein Gott, amazing move und welche Einheit holt
er jetzt raus, boah er holt die neue super Einheit raus und jetzt wird es aber knapp
an der Seite unter Towerfeld, oh mein Gott, nein jetzt gehts los, die sind voll ab, die
sind total eskaliert, das, das ich hab mich da so weggeschmissen bei und die Typen, die
Typen saßen an ihrem Tablet, das war ja auch noch in so einem Studio, das war ja auch
in so einem gemieteten Studio ja und die Typen die saßen an ihren Tablets, 150 LPM, das
war zu geil, ich hab mich so weggeschmissen Alter, oh nee, fuck warum bootet der Scheiß
denn nicht, ok da müssen wir jetzt mal googeln danach, live Manjaro Probleme fixen on stream,
live media, MHWD script, ok, natürlich kann man sowas nur fixen aus der QtVM, nee ich
google nicht in der QtVM, das ist mir zu langsam, die QtVM, die QtVM ist overload mit Grafik
shit, jaja ich glaube auch MHDW ist glaube ich Detection für Grafikkarte, vielleicht
sollte ich mal mit proprietären Treibern booten, ob das dann vielleicht besser geht,
schauen wir mal, ich, ich, ich, ich, google stellt sie jetzt erstmal kurz danach, ich
muss den Kram mal ein bisschen vorschieben, sonst wird das hier nix, live media, MHWD,
also gucken wir mal, live media, MHWD, ahja guck da, siehste, siehste haben wir schon
dabei, max du hast energy, nee hab ich nicht, did you verify doughnuts, bla bla bla, bla
bla bla, ja nein ich hab ne vm, add xdriver, ok, ok nee das bringt nix an, ich mein ich
bin in der vm, hallo, in der vm sollte der Kram ja auch so gefällig sein, warte mal
ich muss mich ein bisschen leiser, deine manjaro vm macht das gleiche, ja wir müssen
es jetzt irgendwie fixen, ok wir so mal hier vm, ja, can start, ok job is running, der
hat genau das gleiche problem wie mir, nee uefi hab ich schon wieder ausgestellt eben,
uefi hab ich schon wieder ausgestellt, was, die forums dudes, die Leute, die regen mich
voll auf im forum immer, die regen mich so auf, was soll der Typ denn noch mehr reinschreiben,
fs cannot start manjaro und forever workstation 16, es hängt beim booten da, not the most
explanatory post, na na na na, da kann man jetzt überhaupt nix reininterpretieren, na
na na na na, dass ist ja nicht gut geschrieben, ist das ernsthaft?
ein netzwerkabel soll ich disconnecten beim start von das kann er nicht ernst meinen,
Der hätte mal ein 28G Memory Dump
Use Manjaro KDE? Nein
Wir einfach eine ältere ISO verwenden?
Was du hast gerade? Driver Mesa gleich Driver Free?
Okay, okay, das probier ich gleich mal
Ansonsten probieren wir eine ältere ISO
Das geht das geht wahrscheinlich auch
Okay ich boot jetzt erst mal und sag
dem er soll proprietäre Treiber laden
Mal gucken ob es dann funktioniert
Wahrscheinlich nicht
So mal schauen vielleicht kriegen wir das jetzt
eigentlich wollte ich mich mit der
Installation mit der Installation
genau wollte ich mich nicht so lange
aufhalten und eher Effektstells machen
aber anscheinend möchte man Jaro sich
nicht einfach so installieren lassen
Ah, ah, knackt das Mikro? Knackt das Mikro?
Nee oder? Knackt nix. Test, test, knackse
Es knackt. Ernsthaft?
Ja eben kurz weil ich wahrscheinlich
dran gestoßen bin
War schon öfters heute also ich höre das
nicht wenn ich das nicht höre heißt
dass das muss irgendwas ein OBS sein
Okay, okay, wisst ihr was ich mache?
Wisst ihr was ich mache? Ich stöpsel es noch mal
kurz ein und aus. So jetzt knackt es mal kurz
So jetzt bin ich wieder da. Schauen wir mal
wenn es weiter knackt müssen wir mal
schauen
okay das funktioniert so nicht
Okay starten wir neu
Also zeigen wir mal. Wo gibt man hier
Boot Options? Wo macht man hier Boot Options? E. So und was
soll man jetzt angeben? Driver gleich Mesa
wo schreibt man das dann rein? Bei den
Kernel Parameters? Oder wie? Oder?
1KS
In ich gleich bin. Quatsch. Chat wieder
Alter. Unten drunter? Meint ihr einfach unten
drunter? Driver. Ohje. Ah ja ich hab's gefunden
So und jetzt muss man was drücken? CTRL C? Ne
F2. CTRL X muss man drücken, genau
Okay das funktioniert nicht. Das war falsch
What? Warum sieht? Was ist das jetzt schon wieder?
Warum sieht das jetzt komplett anders aus?
What the hell?
Dann wahrscheinlich hier an die Kernel
Parameters dran, ne? Denke ich jetzt einfach mal
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung
Achso, hab ich nicht gesehen. Hab ich nicht
gesehen Leute. Okay, broken. Oh, ne. Okay mach
mal schnell checken, schnell checken ob es
jetzt geht. Aber wahrscheinlich geht's jetzt
nicht. Ne, ne das hängt schon wieder. Ich sehe
es. Ich sehe es schon wieder. Ich sehe es schon wieder.
Das hängt schon wieder. Das ist richtig krasser
Das geht zwischenzeitlich immer weg. Warum ist
Snap bei Manjaro dabei? Das frage ich mich
auch. Ich will einfach nur installen. Ich will
einfach nur installen. Okay. Wo stand hier
Driver 3? Ach da. Das wird nichts bringen. Ich nehm
einfach ein älteres Iso und dann funzt's easy
So, postchamp. Geht das jetzt? Huge.
Huh? Huh? You got jebaited. Okay, ich schlatt
mir einfach ein altes Iso runter. So, old, old
version. Komm her. Äh, ins Archiv. So, was ist
aktuell angesagt? 22? Ne, 20, 22 ist grade das
kaputtene, ne? Was hab ich mir runtergeladen
vorhin? 21, 21.02 und wo ist 21.01? Geht's jetzt
vielleicht? Ah, da ist es. Da ist es. Easy. Okay,
dann hat es doch was gebracht mit Driver
Gleichmesser. Okay. Inser, ich hoffe man muss
das nicht jedes Mal patchen nach dem Reboot.
Das wird ziemlich der Sack. Äh ja, weiter. Die
haben ja mittlerweile sogar einen besseren
Installer als das neue Ubuntu Ding. Weiß auch
nicht, was die bei Canonical da machen.
In den letzten Jahren. Okay. Weiter. Moment,
hab ich Sprache auf Deutsch? Ne, ne, ne.
Sprache, Sprache, Englisch. Sonst finde ich
doch da nix. Azerbaijan, gibt's nicht
American Englisch? Jawoll, Kekona. Full, full
style Kekona. Ne, wir sind aber, wir sind
weiter in Berlin. Keyboards. German. No
dead keys. Partition. Ja, mach, mach alles
weg. No swap. Das ist mir vollkommen, vollkommen
egal. Ähm, Master Boot Record. Ja, passt.
Alles gut. Full Name. Max. 0W. 123456. Best
Practice Passwort. Ah, save. Siehste? Save
Passwort. Meckert er bei anderen Passwörtern?
Vielleicht auch nicht. Das ist dem vollkommen
egal. So mag ich das. Einfach mal, endlich
mal ein Installer, der mich nicht darauf
hinweist, ihr Passwort ist kacke. Ja, meinetwegen.
Auch gut. Partitions, mach, install, bam.
Yes. So, während es installiert, guck ich mir
noch ein paar Questions an im Chat. Ja, wie
spricht man, wie spricht man die eigentlich
aus? Canonical, Canonical, äh, wie spricht
man die aus?
Canonical. Canonical. Stimmt doch, ist doch
richtig. Wo liegt denn die, die größten
Unterschiede bei den Distributionen, wenn
es nicht Desktop und installierten Pakete
sind? Das ist zum größten Teil so ein
bisschen die Philosophie dahinter. Also
zum Beispiel Gentoo ist darauf ausgelegt,
dass du deine ganzen Sachen selbst
kompilierst. Also du lädst dir bei Gentoo
keine Pakete runter, sondern du lädst
dir im besten Fall der Fälle Build
Skripte runter, mit denen du dann quasi
lokal bei dir alles kompilierst. Das heißt,
wenn dir einer eine Mail schickt mit einem
Word-Dokument im Anhang, dann musst du
erstmal zwei Stunden Open Office
kompilieren. Das ist die, das ist die
Gentoo-Philosophie oder, oder du brauchst
erstmal 128G RAM für, um Chrome zu
kompilieren. So, du hast zum Beispiel dann
sowas wie Debian, die hauptsächlich
darauf Wert legen, dass sie stabile
Pakete haben, aber halt dafür ein bisschen
ältere. Ubuntu ist so ein schönes
Zwischending. Das ist zwar eigentlich auf
Debian-Basis, aber die haben ein bisschen
neuere und auch teilweise ganz neue
Pakete mit dabei. Dann hast du sowas wie
Arch Linux, was glaube ich somit den
größten, die größte Paketauswahl von
allen hat, weil du hast an sich schon
ganz gutes Paketauswahl, aber dann hast du
auch User Repos, die ein bisschen so
in Richtung Gentoo gehen, wo du eben
Build Skripte hast und den Kram selbst
kompilieren musst. Also ist ein bisschen
die Philosophie dahinter, unterschiedlich
und eben halt auch die Aktualität der
Pakete und wie Releases gemacht werden.
Ubuntu macht einmal im halben Jahr eine
neue Version, Debian macht alle
13 Jahre ungefähr eine neue Version,
CentOS ungefähr alle 12 Jahre eine neue
Version und Suze keine Ahnung, weiß ich
nicht so genau, in welchem Abstand die
neue Version machen. Dann hast du sowas
wie Manjaro, was quasi sich immer
aktuell auf den neuesten Stand
updatet, ist so ein bisschen die
Philosophiefrage dahinter, aber
ansonsten muss man sagen, ist da jetzt
nicht der riesen Unterschied dazwischen,
gut es gibt noch so ein paar Spezialsachen
für Live-CDs und sowas, aber wenn du mal
ein lauffähiges System hast, da ist jetzt
nicht so ein riesen Unterschied, also wenn
du beispielsweise jetzt ein selbst
eingerichtetes Manjaro hast mit
einem Gnome-Desktop oder du hast
einen Debian und Gnome installiert
und benutzt das dann, so groß sind die
Unterschiede da tagtäglich nicht.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Fedora
und Scientific Linux? Scientific Linux
war zumindest die ganze Zeit immer ein
Cento-LNN-Enterprise-Linux-Klon und Fedora
ist ja quasi so das Bleeding Edge
Enterprise Linux, also Fedora ist so
quasi die Testbasis für Red Hat
Enterprise Linux und Scientific Linux
war im Endeffekt ein Red Hat Enterprise
Linux-Klon, sowas wie Cento-S.
Ich habe euch letztens mal
diesen Blogpost gezeigt, dass Cento-S
selbst jetzt ziemlich platt gemacht wurde
von Red Hat und so diese klassische
Cento-S-Sache gar nicht mehr geben wird
mit Cento-S 8 beginnend. Wie es mit
Scientific Linux aussieht, habe ich
ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung. Wo sortiert
man Knoppix ein? Knoppix ist ein Live-CD
und Live-Linux.
So, all done. Guck mal, der Installer, da kann
sich Windows in dem Fall
tatsächlich was abschneiden.
So, kann ich jetzt neu booten und er ist
fertig?
Restart.
Ja, Red Hat für Privatanwender ist ja
auch nur halb so interessant.
Aber gerade im Enterprise-Umfeld, wenn du
4000 Server hast,
niemand hat dort 4000 Red Hat-Lizenzen,
das ist ja gerade der Witz.
Wisst ihr, wie die meisten das machen? Die
meisten größeren Firmen, die Red Hat
einsetzen, die haben, was der Selling-Point
von Scientific Linux ist, die sind ein
Red Hat Enterprise-Klon, nur dass du keine
Red Hat Enterprise Lizenz dafür brauchst.
Die Leute, also viele Unternehmen,
kaufen sich ein paar Rechner und kaufen
sich Red Hat Enterprise Lizenzen und
haben aber, sagen wir mal, die haben 500
Rechner, aber haben nur 5 Rechner mit
Enterprise Lizenz und immer, wenn es
Probleme gibt und man den Red Hat-Support
anschreiben muss, dann hat zufälligerweise
nicht einer von den 495 Rechnern Probleme,
sondern immer einer von diesen fünf
lizenzierten Rechnern hat Probleme, um den
Support maximal ausnutzen zu können.
Aber macht euch nichts draus, der Red Hat-Support
ist eh nicht großartig hilfreich, also
da kann man eigentlich auch getrost ohne
Auskommen.
So, okay, jetzt müssen wir erstmal
Vmware-Tools installieren.
Zack.
Moment, haben die vielleicht Vmware-Tools
schon erstattet? Ist das raus? Nein, natürlich nicht.
Natürlich nicht. Terminal.
Vmware. Nee, ist nicht drauf.
Äh, okay, jetzt steh ich ein bisschen auf
dem Schlauch. Wie heißt denn unter Manjaro
die Vmware-Tools, ähm, und was ist das
standardmäßig für ein User-Dings, egal.
Was, Search? Vmware? Open VmTools heißen
die einfach, easy. Oder, bin ich jetzt auch
draufgekommen. So, man muss das da
installieren, glaub, das da, das da und
das da und noch mehr. Ich glaub, man
braucht noch mehr. Man braucht noch
irgendwie für Copy-Paste brauchen wir noch
irgendwas.
New Colonel Available, ja dann mach, mach, mach
einfach Update. Update.
Meint, hat nicht jemand was von New Colonel
erzählt? Wir machen das über die
Commando-Zeile, weißt du was, mir ist mir
lieber. Äh, Pac-Man minus L, so?
Pac-Man-Commandos, ich kann's mir immer
nicht merken. Ah ja, okay, war richtig.
Did, did, didi, didi, didi, didi.
So. Ah, ist neu. Manjaro.
Settings-Manager. Kann man neuen Colonel
drauf machen, wieso haben wir doch, wir haben
doch einen aktuellen Colonel. Alles gut.
LTS-Colonel, wunderbar. So. Guck mal, ob wir
das Ganze jetzt starten können, Vmware.
Vmware, User, muss man das so starten oder auch nicht, System, CTL, Start, Vmware, nee,
was Vm Tools D, ok auch nicht, ja was war das nochmal für Vmware Tools, ich mach das
so selten, was war das nochmal, Vmware, User, ok jetzt kommen wir zu einem großen Vorteil
von, dass man dann ArchieLux verwendet, wir können jetzt einfach noch Vmware Tools suchen
und gucken in das Wiki rein, Reboot, könnte man mal ausprobieren, ich weiß nicht ob das
was bringt, wir enable mal kurz die ganze Geschichte, weil ich glaube die brauchen wir auf jeden
Fall, Reboot, klappt immer, ja, so, Installation, Open Vmware Tools, Open Vmware Tools, Installation,
Install, Open Vmware Tools, das meinte ich, das muss man noch installieren, genau, sonst
geht Copy Paste nicht richtig, so ein 1080p Monitor, ja, oh guck mal, easy, hat alles
funktioniert, einfach Reboot, Leute, wer hätte das gedacht, Rebooten und gut ist, na dann,
easy Reboot, so, was, hä, was sind das wieder für komische Linux Stellstinger, so das ist
ein XFCE Terminal, oder, so wir müssen erstmal den Hintergrund weg machen, das geht mir nämlich
Transparente, bin ich der einzige der Transparente Terminals nicht mag, gute Voreinstellung,
Scrollback, nicht, nicht, by the way, nicht unlimited, nein, nein, nein, 9.999.999.999,
wie macht man das denn aus, New York Colonel is available, please update, ja, mach ich,
Appearance, Transparent Background hier, Solid Color, jawoll, exellent, machen wir mal Fullscreen,
die es hier angeblich, die angeblich existieren, oh, tatsächlich, um hat er die eben noch nicht
vorher nicht gefunden, ja, was denn jetzt, haben wir jetzt Updates oder net, der erzählt
mir die ganze Zeit, dass es irgendwelche Updates gibt, aber es gibt gar keine Updates,
debated Updates, und Updates, nope, so, erstmal User repo installieren, beste, es gibt nur
ein neueren Colonel, und 12 Updates hat er geschrieben, ja, nothing to do, nothing to
do, gibt es eine Unterschiede, ich glaube zweimal Y ist, dass er immer auch neu vom
repo guckt und die neuesten Metadaten herunterlädt, ach, language packages war das optional, ja,
das hab ich nicht gelesen, wie installiert man das eigentlich schon am Manjaro, Manjaro
settings, settings manager und dann, ach, hier language packs, language packs can create,
additional language packs can be installed, ah ja, mach, yes, dann installieren wir mal
language packs, nicht, dass wir sie brauchen würden, ih, der will das auf Deutsch installieren,
was ist mit dem los, hör mal, plus auf, so, ok, aber vor allem die Tools laufen, da können
wir jetzt mal gucken, ob es Compets gibt, da müssen wir jetzt mal nachschauen, wie
man das macht, hoffentlich geht das überhaupt gescheit in der VM, sollte eigentlich, also
ich hatte das früher definitiv schon in VMs laufen, aber mal schauen, ArchCompets, Compets
gibt's noch, ja, es gibt einen Compets-Fork, der halbwegs aktuell entwickelt wird, guck
mal, Compets reloaded, ach so, ja, die sind aus irgendwelchen Gründen auf Shitlab umgestiegen,
ganz ehrlich, ich hab die Panik, alle auf Gitlab zu wechseln, eh nicht verstanden, Microsoft
hat Gitlab übernommen, und da haben die alles so getan, als wäre morgen, als wäre das
morgen weg, dann hat er gesagt, oh nein, ich muss jetzt sofort wechseln auf irgendeine
Plattform, die sonst keinen Schwanz verwendet, aber Hauptsache nicht Microsoft, tja, dann
waren sie weg, close, die ganzen Hacker-Mans, so, Compets, erst mal schauen, wie funktioniert
das Ganze, jetzt ArchCompets, es wird Zeit für brennende Fenster, so sieht's aus, deswegen
mach ich das heute, und wie kann man Fenster resizen, ok, mit alt, ok, wie geht's, also
es gibt 2 Versions, 0.9, die wollen wir nicht, das ist die Ubuntu-Version, die es sagt, ok,
also wir müssen installieren, Moment, das muss ich jetzt mal nachgucken, also wir müssen
jetzt installieren, was ist das, Compets Easy Patch, das finde ich gut, Compets Easy Patch,
easy, klingt gut, Compets, Compets Easy Patch, und was macht das jetzt, aber das hat auch
bestimmt nichts installiert, Moment, Moment, das ist jetzt, ernsthaft, hat das jetzt Compets
installiert, so easy, Compets das jetzt, oder nicht, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob's funktioniert,
ok, probieren wir mal aus, also, Desktop Cube, Shortcut, Ctrl, was, Ctrl, nee, Ctrl, alt
geht nicht, ich brauch, keine Ahnung, Super, Super und M, irgendwie, das funktioniert nicht,
aber ich glaube, das ist noch gar nicht gestartet jetzt, ich glaube, ich muss noch mal rebooten
oder noch mal neu starten, was haben wir sonst noch jetzt zur Auswahl, Compets, Settings,
Moment, CCSM ist doch schon drauf, also wenn das jetzt mit dem, mit dem Easy Patch getan
ist, ich dachte, ich muss den Kram selbst kompilieren, install, open, anscheinend ist
da echt, das dabei, der Easy Patch, easy, dazu kann ich nur sagen, ok, ja, wir rebooten
einfach mal, ist der Compets dann auch standardmäßig aktiviert, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab das
noch nicht ausprobiert, werden wir gleich sehen, hier, small, habt das gesehen, small
FPS-Anzeige, wo kompets es sich, oh Leute, es fühlt sich gleich noch viel smoother an,
habt das gesehen, hier, huge, huge animations, alter, huge compets animations haben wir schon,
aber Windows-Taste M geht immer noch nicht, jaja, es ist auf jeden Fall an, es ist auf
jeden Fall an, ok, Desktop Rotate Cube, Moment, wie geht das jetzt, Rotate Cube, Desktop Cube,
naja, ich glaube, es ist kaputt gegangen jetzt gerade, oder, ist, ist Compets jetzt wieder
kaputt, ok, das funktioniert ex, exellent, exellent, Compets, man konnte Compets doch
so irgendwie starten, von Hand, wenn es nicht funktioniert hat, einfach Compets, ne, doch,
einfach Compets, jetzt haben wir es wieder, jetzt haben wir es, ok, mein Shortcut geht
nicht, wie kriege ich den Shortcut für den Desktop Cube, Super M geht schonmal nicht,
ich brauche, ich will den Würfel haben Leute, ich will den Würfel haben, vielleicht brauche
ich mehr als, ich habe mehr als, oh Leute, habt ihr es gesehen hier, guck mal, es geht
schon, geht schon los, es geht schon los hier, huge Effekte, muss ich Commands einschalten,
das kann tatsächlich sein, ne, das ist, hier kann ich Keybindings einstellen für alles
mögliche, ok, wir machen jetzt erstmal, erstmal ein bisschen, Wobbly Windows, das ist das
allerwichtigste, Wobbly Windows Leute, oh, wie habe ich das vermisst, alter Leute, endlich
wieder Wobbly Windows, beste, beste, ich sage es euch, da werde ich schwach, da werde ich
schwach, guck mal, man kann sogar, die von Desktop zu Desktop schieben, seht ihr mal,
wie, wow, wow, wow, wow, jetzt habe ich es kaputt gemacht, ich habe es zerstört, das
ist weg, ich habe es kaputt gemacht, das, ok, das hat ein bisschen Probleme, wenn man,
wenn man das zu schnell macht, da geht es irgendwie ein bisschen kaputt dabei, ist es,
guck mal hier, zack, oh, das ist so nice, das ist so nice, ich brauche den Shortcut für
den, wow, what the fuck, wo ist es denn jetzt, Monka, ah, da ist es wieder, guck mal, ok,
das wichtigste ist am Start, Wobbly Windows, Wobbly Windows, so, by the way, das Ding hat
eine wirklich äußerst nützliche Sache, Desktop Zoom, für so Boomer wie mich ist Desktop
Zoom wirklich geil, für so Boomer wie mich ist das wirklich top, ich kann jetzt zum Beispiel
zoomen, Moment, fuck man, was kann ich, Mausbutton, super Mausbutton, guck mal, seht ihr das,
das ist richtig Pock, das ist ohne Scheiß, für Leute, die Sehprobleme haben, ist das
massive nice, das ist viel besser, du kannst einfach mit dem Mausrad jetzt dein Desktop
Zoom, sag mal nicht, dass es nicht cool ist, es kann, das kann sonst kein anderes Linux
Desktop Ding, das ist wirklich nice, guck mal, geht aber auch mit native, mit xfc, ja,
aber bei anderen nicht, also mit i3 kann ich es nicht machen, aber das ist wirklich cool,
kann man den Wobble-Faktor höher stellen, klar, oh, der Wobble-Faktor ist, oh, es ist
gecrashed, nee, der Wobble-Faktor, da ist er wieder, ich mach das mal kurz wieder aus,
also, der Wobble-Faktor, by the way, es gibt noch viel mehr Plugins, die können wir alle
mal installieren, es gibt noch viel mehr Plugins, also den Wobble-Faktor kann man selbstverständlich
höher machen, Leute, könnt ihr euch jetzt vorstellen, als ich das das erste Mal verwendet
hab, dass ich wirklich 2008 oder so, ähm, der Meinung war, nächstes Jahr ist das Jahr
des Linux Desktops, ich, ich ging da, mir ging da voll einer drauf ab früher, leider
ist das nicht, hat sich nicht so durchgesetzt, so, naja, natürlich, also, by the way, wir
haben die neue Compets-Version von Ubuntu-Anschein installiert, das ist nicht Compets-Reloaded,
vielleicht sollten wir, vielleicht probier ich auch gleich nochmal mit Compets-Reloaded
aus, ok, ähm, Wobble-Windows, hier, was, Snap-Windows-Shift, what the fuck, lol, can't wait, jetzt ist es
wieder weg, jetzt hat es sich wieder weg gedreht, ich glaub, ich glaub, das ist nicht so, das
ist nicht so poggers, irgendwie, aber hier ist er, hier ist er wieder, guck mal, aber
wir können das hier hoch machen, guck mal hier, Spring, machen wir hier mal 8, und da
machen wir keine Ahnung, 16, oah, guckt euch jetzt mal an, wie es wobbelt, Leuchtpapier,
für den Sub, guckt euch mal an, 60 FPS wabbelnde Fenster, ist das nicht einfach der Wahnsinn,
wir stellen das, was war denn das jetzt, was war denn das ursprünglich, das hier war 8
und das hier war 3, oh, ups, fuck, das hier war 3, ne, ich glaub, so war es ursprünglich,
so, aber ich brauch den Desktop-Würfel, ich, ich brauch unbedingt den, den, ups, das hab
ich geklaust, DCSM, ja, ich brauch den, den Würfel, Desktop-Cube, one big cube, Alt-Control
kann ich ja nicht machen, also wir machen jetzt, Control, Control-Shift-Down, geht nicht, hm,
was mach ich denn falsch, also, es ist auf jeden Fall an, mach ich einfach mal Control-Down,
ok, ne, ich mach da irgendwas falsch, es ist Unfold-Cube-Key, was muss ich denn dafür
machen, dass das funktioniert, Appearance, ob das ein Vmware-Problem ist, ne, aber dann
wird der andere Kram doch auch nicht funktionieren, du hast nur zwei Flächen, stimmt, das könnt's
wirklich sein, äh, wie macht man hier mehr Desktops, äh, Moment, warte mal, äh, hä,
so, ich hab jetzt angeblich 7 Workspaces und wo sind die, ich hab da nen Workspace und
da nen Workspace, Reboot, meint ihr ernsthaft Reboot hilft, vielleicht muss ich hier Workspace
erst noch einstellen, Workspace, ne, ok Leute, Reboot, mal gucken, hat sich das jetzt automatisch
gestartet, du wurdest von Venice Unleashed Discord gebannt, ja wenn du gegen irgendwelche
Tools verstoßen hast, dann vielleicht sogar zurecht, ja man war's ja nett, ne, warum hab
ich so wenig Workspaces hier, was ist das, tja, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das
ist, wie krieg ich das jetzt hin, also eingeschaltet ist es, Workspace, wie, the number of Workspaces
man, will ich verappeln, null heißt der, ok, was mach ich denn hier jetzt verkehrt, also
der Wurfelstart, ich will den Würfel haben Leute, ich, ich will den Würfel haben, ich
brauch den Desktop Cube, Control Down, funktioniert nicht, ihm fehlen kritische Informationen,
jaja, fehlen wir, wie ging das denn nochmal, das war doch eigentlich Unfault Key und dann
ist gut, ne, Enter, ne, der hat, der hat sich das ja schon gemerkt, wow, what the fuck, kann
es sein, dass das XFCE Zeug damit, damit nicht, damit nicht klar kommt, dass es da irgendwelche
Probleme damit hat, äh, Moment, wir machen mal kurz, wir machen das mal kurz aus, wie,
wie, wie, wie machen wir das, hier, ne, Moment, jetzt hab ich, jetzt hab ich irgendwas, man,
wie macht man Compets jetzt überhaupt wieder aus, ah, wisst ihr was, wir machen das die
Holzhammer Methode, kill, null, wait, kick, wait, ah, yes, so, perfekt, Compets gekillt,
jetzt gehen die Workspaces gar nicht mehr, ich glaub, ich glaub, das Workspaces Ding
ist RIP, ich glaub, ich glaub, das Workspaces Ding ist RIP, guck mal, mein Terminal ist
auch kaputt, ich kann immer mal schreien hier drin, okay, Leute, ich muss, muss mich ausloggen
irgendwie, geht vielleicht anders, wie loggt man sich hier aus, da, Logout, RIP, okay,
es wobbelt wieder, ich glaub, das ist einfach broken, ich glaub, das ist einfach broken
mit den XFCE Workspaces, ich installier jetzt das andere Compets, aber Moment, vorher, vorher
muss ich euch noch mal eines der besten Effekte überhaupt zeigen, für den Fall der Fälle,
dass es danach nicht funktioniert, mal gucken, was es hier noch für Settings gibt, okay,
das sieht jetzt auch nicht wirklich besser aus, ehrlich gesagt, ja, das ist schon schöner,
ich hatte noch mal Compets CCL, mach ich, mach ich, Advanced Settings, hey, das hat man,
das hat man nicht gebraucht, eher Cube, kann man das hier, Desktop Cube, nee, nee, Control
Down, das ist, das ist aus irgendwelchen Gründen, tut, tut das nicht, ja, aber ich muss euch
den besten Effekt überhaupt zeigen, Moment, das meine ich jetzt aber gar nicht, das meine
ich nicht, man kann jetzt auf dem Bildschirm rumfackeln, okay, wo ist Fenster abbrennen,
ist das nicht, ist das nicht installiert, da kriegst du ja Anfälle, wenn du das siehst,
Effects, also Water Effect ist schon mal installiert, ist schon mal drauf, Control, super, Toggle
Rain, Shift F9, das ist doch mal was, Shift F8, passiert nichts, was, 3D Windows ist aus,
Moment, While Rotating the Cube, das ist wieder was anderes, nee, nee, der Cube, aber man
konnte doch die Fenster abbrennen lassen, wie konnte man die Fenster, das ist unter
Animations, ich hab das schon ganz lange nicht mal verwendet, okay, also Animations, Animations
plus Zoom, ich brauch Close Effect, Close Effect und dann Feuer, Close Animation, wo
ist das Feuer, Zoom, nein, da ist kein Feuer dabei, ich mein man kann auch Random Effects
machen, das ist dann auch ganz grausam, guckt euch das mal an, hä, sollte das jetzt nicht,
oder war Close das hier, jetzt haben wir Random Effect beim Schließen, nee, nee, nee, das
ist nicht so wie ich das in Erinnerung, das ist nicht nur das wie ich das in Erinnerung
hab, warte mal Leute, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, Minimize, Minimize Animation,
da beißt sich doch irgendwas mit den Eingebauten, oder, das kann doch nicht sein, dass das nicht
funktioniert, so, Effects, 3D Windows haben wir an, ja Motion Blur, Blur Windows, das
sackt halt ein bisschen, ne, braucht kein Mensch, Animation Plus, wo war denn jetzt das Feuer,
und auch die Animationen hier tun nicht, ach muss man hier random, muss man hier random
mal einstellen, ach hier random, ok, ach jetzt versteh ich's, ok, hier musst du oben einstellen,
du willst Random Effect haben, jetzt kannst du sagen welchen Random Effect willst du
haben, ja, das ist jetzt nice, guckt euch das mal an hier, jetzt hat jedes Fenster exquisite
eigene Schließen Animation, so muss das sein, so mag ich das, ui und wobbly, brauchst du
Compiz Plugins, ich glaub die hab ich hier, ich muss doch das andere installieren, Compiz,
Compiz Plus, Moment, wie hieß das jetzt, Browser, ja, also wir brauchen, ne wir müssen doch
das andere installieren, Plugins extra, Compiz extra, ja wir müssen es wieder runterschmeißen,
das hier brauchen wir, wir müssen den Kram jetzt, die Hardcore Self-Compiled Variante
muss sein, weil das hier hat keine Feuereffekte, ich mein wir können doch nicht ernsthaft,
wir können doch nicht ernsthaft was verwenden, was keine, was keine, vielleicht soll ich
Mate Compatibility anmachen, ich mein das ist ja fast, fast ein Mate, was hatte ich noch
mal für den Würfel, mal kurz gucken ob der Würfel jetzt, Control Down, ne geht nicht,
mein Control Down das frisst der gar nicht, ok, Control, wir machen einfach Alt, Control,
ne Control Alt Shift, Control Down, ne, keine Chance, das macht er nicht, gut, deinstallieren
wir da, weg damit, Compiz Easy Patch, alles fort und selbst Kompilieren, so, also was
müssen wir installieren, wir brauchen Compiz Core, ok das installieren wir zuerst, Compiz
Core, ok das könnte jetzt ein bisschen dauern, weil er den Kram Kompilieren muss, hoffentlich
funktioniert das überhaupt, Moment ich hab doch Compiz deinstalliert, was hat er jetzt
für Schmerzen, ah Strip Binary, Strip ist nicht drauf, ok, Strip, was muss ich dafür
installieren, irgendwie Base Utils oder was muss man dafür installieren, Manjaro Strip
Binary, Base Devil, er bin Utils, Base Devil können wir auch mal installieren, schadet
auf jeden Fall nicht, ganz, ganz, ganz, ne Pacman ging das, Pacman US Base war das so,
ja wir müssen erst mal Compiz so installieren, so und jetzt Compiz, wo haben wirs, Core hieß
das ne, ja Bäm, so und jetzt kann er ne Runde vor sich hin Kompilieren, mal gucken wie lang
das braucht, ich denke mal das geht, weil das ist nicht so wahnsinnig grof, vielleicht haben
wir auch irgendwelche Abhängigkeiten nicht, oh oje, Makros, MonkaS, ah jetzt Compiler
Output, ich verstehe jede Zeile Chat, ah alles klar was da passiert, logisch, logisch, ich
denke, ich denke, oh was da los, war nur ne Warning, install hat funktioniert, easy, einfach
random irgendwas installiert, easy as fuck, letztendlich ist es überhaupt kein Problem,
jedes Mal wenn ich ein NPM Update mache installiere ich eh das halbe Internet, insofern wo ist
das Problem, ok jetzt brauchen wir noch CCSM, Compiz, was muss ich da jetzt installieren,
3, Bäm, was dich hat mal einer, Cooper schreibt, ihn hat mal einer in der Bahn angesprochen,
weil ich ein Paket gebaut habe, im Terminal dachte ich Hacke das Wlan, war das, war das
etwas älter, ältere Herr, oder was, richtige Hacker man, hä ich hab, das hab ich doch
oben, ach Moment es hat Abhängigkeiten zu dem anderen, ich hab es falsch versucht zu
installieren, was muss ich denn jetzt installieren, was, Cack wait, was muss ich jetzt installieren,
ok, Compiz plugin, also was brauch ich, das haben wir installiert, 4 und 5 brauch ich
ja, mit der Version stimmts aber, wait a minute, passt zum, mal gucken ob das jetzt zu meinem
Compiz passt, zack, ich blick gerade, ja ja, hä Moment was hab ich denn da eben installiert,
ich hab Compiz Core installiert, ok wunderbar, ich bin auch gerade nicht verwirrt, also welche
Packages muss ich denn jetzt überhaupt installieren, ich hab installiert eben, sag mal find nur
ich das übelst anstrengend um dieses Terminal zu gucken, ich weiß nicht woran das liegt,
aber das so krass, krass helle Farbe, ich muss mal kurz den Hintergrund umstellen, presets,
ja schon besser, so was hab ich denn da eben installiert, Compiz Core hab ich installiert,
8.8, eher 8.18, Moment hätte das jetzt doch mit meinem Easy Patch funktioniert, oder ist
das kaputt, weil ich hab den doch, ich installiere das doch, guck mal ich installiere das was
genau passend ist zu meiner Compiz Version, 4, was will der denn, was will der Typ denn
von mir hier, was, Remove Compiz Easy Patch, was will der denn mit seinem Compiz Easy Patch,
das passt doch überhaupt nicht dafür, was ist das für nen Schwachsinn, ok so einfach
ist es da neulich wie ich gedacht hab, aber guck mal ich mein, da ist doch irgendwie Mist
in den Packages drinne oder, das check ich jetzt nicht, soll ich vielleicht das da installieren,
passt das dann besser, 10, ne das ist experimental extra, da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht, ok ich
kann neuen installieren, ich hab keine Ahnung was ich da jetzt installieren muss, mit Gentoo
wäre das nicht passiert, ja das stimmt, ne mal easy, das kann ich machen, aber das passt
doch von der Version her gar nicht, das passt ja von der Version her gar nicht, guck mal,
so der will jetzt Easy Patch gleich installieren, also ich mach jetzt, ich installiere jetzt
extra Plugins, so 5, so, 2 Providers, ja 1 ist ok, guck mal die Version passt doch überhaupt
nicht dazu, das ist 8.18 und das ist 9.14, das kann doch überhaupt nicht miteinander
funktionieren, das kackt beim kombinieren wahrscheinlich auch gleich ab, oder auch nicht,
schauen wir mal, mit Cobol wäre das nicht passiert, vielleicht oder die zählen die
Version irgendwie anders, ne siehst du, sag ich doch, funktioniert nicht, was ist B-Cobb,
B-Cobb, wtf, siehst du das passt, ne Leute das passt nicht, ich glaub die Compets Pakete
sind einfach Fail, ich glaub die Compets Pakete sacken einfach, ja gut da können wir das,
da können wir nichts machen, also da irgendwie, also was ich nicht machen werde ist mit dem
Kram von GitHub runterladen und dort, guck mal hier stehen doch sogar explizit dahinter
welche User Repos ich nehmen soll, ich soll Compets Core installieren, Compets Core CCSM,
das da und das da, ok, jetzt machen wir jetzt einfach mal, Compets Core, Compets Core, da
gibt's ja, gibt's ja nur den, Compets Core 8.8.dings 2, jawoll, gut, machen wir, so und
dann CCSM 8.8.10, scheint doch äußerst big brain zu sein, was man da, was man da braucht,
Compets GTK braucht man doch, ok, Compets minus GTK, das hatten wir eben schon installiert,
das hatten wir doch eben schon installiert, das ist aber Compets 9.1 und Compets 9.1 hat
keine krassen Feuereffekte, ich brauch huge Feuereffekte, ok, ist Compets Manjaro, ist
das, ist das 8.8.10 oder ist das 9.0 irgendwas, gibt's doch überhaupt nicht, mal gucken was
der da jetzt versucht zu installieren, wenn ich das so macht, ja, ja, chat, es gibt einen
Compets Easy Patch, meinst du das da, das ist was anderes, so, jetzt haben wir den Manjaro
GTK installiert, das hat funktioniert, so und jetzt installieren wir das Zeug aus den
Depots, Compets Core haben wir, CCSM, CCSM, so und da brauchen wir jetzt hier 8.8.10,
was anderes gibt's da ja nicht, ok, da oben, das, das gibt's noch, aber ich glaube nicht,
dass wir das brauchen, das ergibt ja keinen Sinn, warum will der dieses fucking Compets
Easy Patch installieren, gehst du fort, das ist falsch, ok, dann installier ich doch mal
das, aber das heißt doch an, das funktioniert nicht, das ist, das ist broken, das ist, das
ist broken, man muss da ernsthaft den Easy Patch, Compets Easy Patch installieren, was
ich aber mit normalem Compets beißt, ach du große, nee, das mach ich nicht, das mach
ich nicht Leute, vergesst es, das mach ich nicht, almighty mau, was willst du eigentlich,
chat geht mir nicht auf den Keks, ihr habt doch genau gesehen, was ich gemacht hab, hört
auf hier so nervig rum zu Backseiten, Rage Mode, Alter, warum ist das so bescheuert gemacht,
warum hängt das eine von dem anderen ab, hm, ich glaube, dass das stimmt, also entweder
liegt das daran, weil das nicht mit irgendwelchen Manjaro Geschichten zurecht kommt, oder die
Buildscripts sind falsch, weil wenn ich das, ja, der will immer diesen kacke Easy Patch
installieren, ja, remove core, jawoll, ja kacke, nee das funktioniert nicht, das haben wir
nämlich schon ausprobiert vorhin, das kompiliert jetzt nicht, na super, das ist ja doof, nee,
okay, da ist irgendwas kaputt, da können wir jetzt nicht machen, weil das sind exakt
die Repos aus dem Guide, nee, das brauchen wir alles nicht, nee, das funktioniert nicht,
dann können wir tatsächlich nur den Easy Mode verwenden, was wir ganz am Anfang schon
gemacht haben, ja, jetzt haben wir den Easy Mode Patch drauf, das ist aber dumm, ich
brauch Feuereffekte, alter Leute, ich brauch Feuereffekte, ohne Feuereffekt kann ich nicht
schlafen gehen heute Mittag, das wirkt gut, ja, das zählt, der Settings Manager ist das
eine, aber das hier ist ja eigentlich das hauptsächliche Problem, dass die Plugins
nicht funktionieren, tja, Leben am Limit sag ich da nur, weil das sind auch alles für
die alten, und das sackt ja mal mega, okay, vielleicht haben die auch wirklich nur eine
andere Nummerierung, was keinen Sinn ergibt, aber okay, doch, das steht hier als Dependency,
guck, das steht hier als Dependency, Compiz Easy Patch, wobei, warte mal, was ist, Moment,
Moment, Moment, was ist Compiz, was ist Compiz, B-Cop, okay, ich installiere den ganzen Kram
nochmal, das macht komische Dinger, was ist, Compiz, Compiz B-Cop installieren wir jetzt,
beste, Moment, das muss ich vorher installieren, okay, Compiz, ich hab's doch schon Removed,
was so geil ist, Compiz, B-Cop, und warum hat Compiz, B-Cop, Compiz Easy Patch als, das
ist doch das eigentliche Problem, warum hat, hat eine Compiz, Moment, Moment, Moment, what
the fuck, das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn, das hat Compiz Core als Abkennung, also
und das hat Compiz Easy Patch als Abhängigkeit, was eine 914 ist und das andere ist eine 818,
das ergibt hinten und vorne keinen Sinn, das ergibt hinten und vorne keinen Sinn,
ja, da machst du nichts, ne, nein, ich möchte das nicht co-maintainern, ich will's einfach
nur verwenden, ne, das klappt nicht, das sackt aber, das, das, das ist ja doof, ich brauch
den Feuereffekt, Leute, ich installiere mir gleich Ubuntu 1204, ne, ich hab keinen Bock,
selbst Bildsachen anzupassen, ich installiere mir gleich Ubuntu 1204, da ist das alles dabei
und funktioniert, was, ach Moment, das hat der nur zum Kompilieren gebraucht, oder was,
wait a minute, wait a minute, what, das ist ja, das ist ja abfuck hoch 10, okay, Compiz
Core, okay, okay, das kann man, das kriegen wir glaub ich nicht installiert, ne, oh jetzt
hab ich's kaputt gemacht, ach so, da findet nix, ach du Scheiße, okay, okay, okay, okay,
also wir brauchen Compiz Core, also mal, übrigens das XFCE Terminal, das ist ja, das ist ja
kaum lesbar, Alter, okay, wir brauchen 6 und wir brauchen diesen komischen B-Cop, wo
ist der B-Cop, seht jemand diesen komischen B-Cop, Leute, ich kann das Terminal nicht
lesen von XFCE, das ist mir zu, ah ja, so ist schon, so ist schon besser, 16, ach jetzt
der Chat ist mit einem Bericht massive brained, 16, guck mal, das ist total, das ist total
wir, das Held von Compiz Easypatch ab, was ne neuere Version ist und das andere, Moment,
vielleicht sollte ich, Moment, Moment, Moment, vielleicht sag ich einfach, der soll die,
der soll den Kram da entfernen, das könnte man nämlich auch machen, also wir brauchen,
was, 6 und 16 war das, ne, yeah, warte mal, 6 und 16, remove, make dependencies after
this one, yes, Alter, boah, what the fuck, remove Compiz Easypatch, ich weiß nicht ob
ich das entfernen darf, weil, wenn ich das jetzt nicht entferne kann das andere nicht
installieren, ok, yes, yes, ja, ja, wir haben es geschafft, exquisite, exzellent, exzellent,
ok das war jetzt, das war jetzt nicht so easy wie ich mir das vorgestellt hab, ok, so jetzt
kann man die Plugins installieren, 1, easy, war easy, first try Leute, first try, so das
installieren wir jetzt, dann installieren wir noch die extra Plugins, so das sollte jetzt
eigentlich durchlaufen, exquisite, exquisite, exquisite, ah, natürlich, klar, ne, easy,
ist das C++ Zeug, hab ich das richtig gesehen, sind das C++ Files gewesen gerade dazwischen,
kein Wunder, dass es nicht funktioniert, ich mach das immer so, immer, also ich mach
ehrlich gesagt, in Wirklichkeit ist das so, ich geh dann morgens eigentlich aufs Klo
nachdem ich aufstehe, stell mich auf meine Waage und während die Waage quasi zum einpendeln
wartet, dass es mich schmieken kann, mach ich das morgens immer, von Hand, selbstverständlich,
so, extra installieren, 1, das Terminal suckt Hardcore, ne, warum ist das Terminal so schlecht,
ah, Hacker, Hacker Mode, Hacker Mode am Start, okay, das ist vielleicht noch ein bisschen
besser, Tango, extra, oh fuck, und warum läuft das Wobbly überhaupt noch, ach, weil es immer
noch im Rahmen drinne ist, okay, so, jetzt haben wir das, jetzt brauchen wir als letztes
noch den aktuellen CCSM, das jetzt sollte jetzt aber eigentlich auch funktionieren,
WLCCSM, also 3, nein, kein easy install, kein easy install, hörst du auf, oh, hab ich mich
vertan, ne, passt doch, 0818 ist doch okay, hm, warum das und nicht das da, ne, ne, ne,
ne, das ist schon richtig, was ich hier installieren will, ne, aber eine Make-Dependency, die ich
nicht installieren kann, weil ich was Konfliktes damit hab, okay, guck mal mal, ja, ne, geht
nicht, na, super, nein, okay, vielleicht dann das 6er, vielleicht geht das dann, easy, es
wird immer diesen komischen easy, nein, ja, aber das funktioniert nicht, nein, okay, jetzt
krieg ich den Kram nicht installiert, so, aber wir sollten das zumindest, aber ich reboote
mal schnell, wir sollten das zumindest jetzt gestartet bekommen schon mal, doch, ich hab
noch ne Idee, wie wir das machen können, PickBrain, ich deinstallier das nochmal und füg das dann
alles nochmal hinzu und dann macht er das hoffentlich in der richtigen Reihenfolge,
ja, so, okay, es ist nicht aktiviert, so, machen wir mal Compets an, Compets, oh, ah,
minus, minus Replays, muss man da machen damals, ah, ist es jetzt an? Funzt das jetzt? Weiß
ich, ob es jetzt funktioniert, aber ich brauch hier den Compet Settings Manager, ja, das
hat funktioniert, okay, aber ohne den Compet Settings Manager komm ich nicht weit, okay,
das ist Sack, ja, Dependency hält, Tetris, trifft es ganz gut, okay, den kann ich nicht
installieren, Simple Compets Configuration Manager, darf ich den vielleicht installieren?
Aber der ist 814, der ergibt ja gar keinen Sinn, nee, nee, nee, nee, okay, den darf
ich installieren? Nein, nein, nein, Python 2 wollte mich rollen, was ist denn das für
eine antike Geschichte? Oh Leute, ich habe es kaputt gemacht, Relog, okay, ich glaube,
ich muss es noch mal deinstallieren und dann gleich CCMM am Anfang mitinstallieren, MonkaS,
oh, Hilfe, was war man da jetzt, Terminal, also, so, fett machen das Ganze, also ich installiere
die, kann man ein Sternchen machen, ja, wahrscheinlich, ja, nee, Backslash-Sternchen, nee, kann man
doch nicht ein Sternchen machen, ist ja fail, so, okay, alles klar, also, wir installieren
jetzt das da, Compets Core und das andere hieß Compets Settings Manager, nee, einfach
nur CCSM, okay, kann man eigentlich sowas hier machen jetzt? Na, Compets Easy Patch,
nee, nee, nee, nee, keinen Compets Easy Patch, was macht der jetzt, null, Valder,
dieses gbait? So, also, die 3 Sachen brauchen wir jetzt, okay, Compets, also schauen wir
mal, also ich weiß noch, wir brauchen Compets Core, das ist echt scheiße zu lesen das Terminal,
Das liegt, das liegt an einer Schriftart. Ich sag so, Schriftart zack, ich brauch eine andere Schriftart.
Ist Hack dabei? Hackfont?
Kein Hack...
Ohne Hack?
Wie kann man, wie kann man das überhaupt aus?
Wie kann man das überhaupt, äh, so... Hackfont?
Erstmal...
Erstmal ein richtiger...
Äh, Moment, Pearl? What? Moment, Zack.
Was zum...
Das will ich nicht installieren.
Äh...
Hack... Hackfont! Wo ist er?
Wo ist Hack?
Wo ist er denn?
Das heißt bestimmt nicht Hackfont, sondern irgendwie so...
TTF-Hack, jawoll, yes.
So, erstmal, erstmal ordentliche, ordentliche Font. Ohne ordentliche Font geht hier nix.
Ohne ordentliche Font geht hier nix.
Appearance, Hack.
Oh, fuck, ich noob, jetzt hab ich zugeklickt, null.
Hack.
Okay.
Ist das jetzt besser zu lesen?
Oh, viel besser, Leute, viel besser zu lesen. Huge lesbar.
Huge lesbar.
True, true.
Okay, also wir brauchen Compets...
Wir brauchen das da.
Wir brauchen Compets core, das da.
Und das andere war 16, ne?
B-Cop, 16.
4, 6, 16 brauchen wir.
Yes.
Weiter, weiter.
Easy Patch, ja, okay, meinetwegen, mach.
Hoffentlich geht das jetzt.
Bless, bless RNG, Alter.
Compets easy patch, Compets easy patch, yes.
Wie?
Yes, yes, wir installieren...
Das ist mir zu dumm.
Die falsche Reihenfolge, ne, ne, die Reihenfolge sollte der eigentlich checken.
Okay, also wir brauchen Compets core, das da.
Und das sollte der eigentlich checken.
Oh, Leute, stopp, das wird nix.
Was?
Der disloafel hat den Fehler gefunden, ja, hier stand der Fehler, guck da.
Da hier.
Okay.
Ja, ich hab keinen Schimmer, wie ich das dem jetzt beibringe ehrlich gesagt.
Nee, Compets Easy Patch funktioniert überhaupt nicht, das ist das neue Ubuntu Compets und
das ist Compets Reloaded.
So, also was hatten wir jetzt installiert, vier, sechs, acht, vielleicht muss man das
mal 16 zuerst machen, ok, 16, 16 war mal zuerst, 16, aber das hat er schon gecheckt, das hat
er eigentlich schon kapiert.
Fünf brauchst du nicht, nee, ich kann nicht mal machen, aber glaube ich nicht und was
habe ich noch gebraucht, Compets GTK habe ich noch gebraucht, ne, sieben, aber der sollte
das doch eigentlich checken.
Remove Dependencies After Install, yes, und es funktioniert ja nicht, so, yes, Moment,
no, wait a minute, yes, und nachher wieder installieren, nee, ah, keck wait, MonkaS alter,
doch was habe ich eben dafür Version installiert, was war das hier, acht, wo ist es, hier, 16,
6, 4, 5, 7, Monka Hyper S, alter, yes, yes, wir sehen wohl, wir haben alles schon durch,
so, yes, wir müssen das entfernen, wenn wir es nicht entfernen, dann geht es nicht, yes,
yes, das geht mir echt hart koffensack, der Kram, ne, vor allem warum hat irgendeine kack
alte Version Abhängigkeiten überhaupt da drauf, was soll das denn, äh, passt ja, warum
hat das überhaupt Abhängigkeiten dazu, was soll das, das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn,
das ist 8, 18, das ist 9, 14, und der will unbedingt einen Easy Patch haben, ne, weißt
du was, leck mich, ich hab keinen Bock mehr, das wird zu dumm, bam, Power off, weg, zack,
so, fertig, denied, gibt's nicht, rage quit, oh, perfekt, alter, meine Güte, das ist noch
nicht in Ernst, aber ich kann da nicht wirklich jemand böse sein, weil das ist ja nur wirklich
keine supporteten Geschichten, die ich da probiere, aber ich muss mal kurz Licht einschalten
hier bei mir schnell, so, ist an, boah, meine Güte, das war mir zu viel Gunde, zumal ich
heute auch halb den Tag auf dem Klo gehockt hab, Pepo, Pepo, Pupu, alter, vielleicht
bin ich einfach brainmäßig nicht genug da, meine Güte, was ein Akt, oder, das ist doch
nicht normal, warum ist eigentlich dieses GIF, warum sind eigentlich alle GIFs in der
richtigen Geschwindigkeit nur Pepo Pupu nicht, der ist ja am hyperkacken gerade bei dem GIF,
und wenn ihr hier mal guckt, das GIF an sich ist richtig, hier, GIF, äh, hier, auch Geschwindigkeit
richtig, guck mal, hier ist das GIF in Ordnung, aber das WPF-Overlay kann das nicht, und es
ist am hyperschitten, woher bekommst du die GIFs, einfach downloaden über Google, Chat
im Weg, ah, Chat im Weg, Moment, guck da unten, hier, GIF vollkommen in Ordnung, ja, wenn
du keinen Bock hast alle zu suchen, dann kriegst du sie auch nicht, oh, sorry, Monka Toss GIFs
hier am Start, jetzt noch Stadia, Moment, Moment, Stadia geht nur in Kombination mit,
oder auch alternativ in Kombination mit, was anderes kann man zu Stadia ja eh nicht sagen,
du kannst das Meambot ja mal im Stream überarbeiten, ich glaube nicht, dass ich das irgendwie überarbeiten
kann, was ich da eklige Software zusammen gewurstet habe, das einzige, was ich machen
könnte ist das Overlay nochmal komplett neu machen, und nicht mit WPF, sondern wahrscheinlich
mit FFM-Pack zum Rendern und dann irgendwie ja mal gucken, das würde funktionieren, dann
sind wahrscheinlich die GIFs dann zumindest von der Geschwindigkeit her besser, ja, ich
habe gerade eine Mail gekriegt, die muss ich mal kurz lesen.
OK.
Mal kurz was antworten
Ich sehe hier wieder Trends auf Twitter
Ich darf mich nicht triggern lassen auf diese Trends zu klicken, weil wenn ich auf diese Trends klicke in Twitter, dann weiß ich ich reg mich innerhalb von 5 Minuten schon wieder auf
So ich will aber noch wissen wer in die Fresse gehauen kriegt, das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken
Okay
Alles dicht machen, okay wer macht irgen- ne ne, schlag ins Gesicht, okay
Was ist wieder, wer hat wieder, wer hat wieder irgendwas gesagt, was Twitter nicht gefällt
Was ist hier los, ich will es nicht wissen, ich will es- nein Max, ich gucke mir das nicht an
Ich gucke mir das nicht an, ich reg mich immer über Twitter auf oder nicht nur über Twitter, generell über alle Leute, die dummes Zeug von sich geben
Ich reg mich dazu, ich kann mir das nicht angucken
Kennst du codegame.com?
Nein, kenn ich nicht
Kenn ich nicht
Was ist das denn?
Zeig mal her
Ach, Serious Max hast du mich letztens mal so einen Test mit Fake News geschickt, den könnten wir tatsächlich jetzt mal eben im Stream machen
Was hältst du davon?
Mein alten PC i7 48 CPU 16 GB RAM in einen Server 2 HU Case einzubauen und dann als Server zu verwenden
Ist das sinnvoll?
Wenn du die Leistung brauchst, ist das sinnvoll, kann man machen ja
Kommt darauf an, wie alt das ganze ist, ob das nicht noch einer der älteren Generationen ist, die massig viel, massig viel Strom brauchen
Oder Serious Max, warst du das nicht, der irgendwas mit News letztens irgendwie gepostet hast?
Der News-Test, genau
Den wollten wir auch mal im Stream machen
Genau, genau
Hey, kannst du das Chain-Lore?
Ich brauch irgendwas clickbaitiges, was nicht so clickbaitig aussieht
Wenn der 8 Jahre alt ist, dann zieht er wahrscheinlich ein bisschen viel Strom
Aber nichtsdestotrotz muss man sagen, wenn du dir mal rechnest, was aktuelle Sachen kosten
Da kannst du sowas ganz schön lang laufen lassen, dass du mit der Stromersparnis das Geld wieder drinne hast
Achso, exkurs, ich lerne lieber mal dafür
Klingt sinnvoller
Gibt's ja schon, gibt's ja schon
So, was ist das hier, was?
Ist das hier Coding-Game?
Ok, das ist, das ist Big Brain-Time
Ist YouTube down?
Ich würde sagen, YouTube ist nicht down, nein
YouTube läuft noch
Die Playlist war nur fertig
Das ist, das ist mal richtig Big Brain-Time
Learn New Concepts, was haben wir mit Fun Coding-Challenges?
Oh nee, da hab ich heute kein Brain für
Coding-Challenges mit anderen Leuten dabei, ok, das speichere ich mir mal
Das ist bestimmt eine ganz coole Sache
Ihr habt das im Discord schon zusammen gemacht, ja?
Guckt mal hier, der Chat ist nicht nur im Chat Big Brain, der Chat ist auch im Discord Big Brain
Ok
Nice
Oh
Leute, ich mach jetzt glaube ich nicht den Test oder sonst was, ich geh jetzt glaube ich off
Es hat heute nicht so wirklich funktioniert, wie ich mir das vorgestellt hab
Auch wenn wir erst 2 Stunden non sind
Aber ich geh jetzt auf und guck noch ein bisschen Twitch
Ich guck jetzt noch, ich guck jetzt noch ein paar Pool-Streams, Leute
Ein Fall of Whistler Studio Code Sync-Settings habe ich
Ist der Frazier on?
Der Frazier ist on
4 Stunden 30, der ist da, der kennt nix
Der kennt nix im Kreiselgrind
Da hat er keine Schmerzen mit, der Kreiselgrindet
Ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste
Wir reden jetzt in Frazier, da ist er
Was spielt er denn, also was er spielt ist mir klar, was spielt er mit der Tamer, ne
Was ist das?
Dark Knight ist das, oder? Ja
Excellent, excellent
Also Leute, könnt ihr mal ne Runde rumspermen
Wir sehen uns dann im nächsten Stream, machts gut, bis dann, see you